all right i am feeling under the weather
today so uh i'm not going into the
office i'm just gonna record this at
home uh the moonlight trailer looks cool
right it looks really really really
really cool here's the funny thing about
this is it's leaving everybody baffled
right for those of you guys who are
familiar with comics explain we'll do a
video on arthur harrow uh it's kind of
strange because everywhere i've looked
it's like
ethan hawk is playing randall spector
and then the subtitles for the trailer
identify him as arthur harrow so i guess
he's playing arthur harrow and of course
he also said his character was based off
david koresh in this video i'll give you
guys some real life history on david
koresh right because the the whole
events surrounding him and like the
siege on waco and all that kind of stuff
is absolutely crazy right but let's talk
about this trailer let's do a trailer
breakdown first right so
as you go through the trailer the funny
thing about this there's not a whole lot
to go on here right the trailer is
pretty straightforward but it does give
us some pretty cool concepts right so
mark spector at least when we're
introduced to to him or at least the
steve grant persona that he appears to
be an employee of a museum instead of
him having a mercenary passed maybe he
does right at the 36 second mark it
looks like he's basically standing
behind a bank of cash registers right
when the woman is telling him like he's
useless and things like that so he's a
guy that seems to like confidence
doesn't really know his own self-worth
and that kind of a thing and he presents
the steve grant identity to her now in
marvel comics steve grant is one of the
identities of mark spector right a lot
of people refer to mark spector as like
marvel's version of batman and in a lot
of way he is right i mean he's almost
identical to batman but the big
difference between him is that mark
spector got lost in his personalities
and batman did not right so talk about
batman here for a second there's more to
the batman mythos than just bruce wayne
running around and beating up people in
the middle of the night that he's
actually got several identities that
allow him to serve the purpose of
attacking crime from different ways so
you have bruce wayne of course the
actual identity of this guy right he's
the super rich dude from the wayne
family and he uses his money for
charitable goals and tries to help
gotham from the financial side but it
also allows him to keep his eye on
white-collar crime right it's people who
are super rich and are breaking the law
and then of course he appears to them as
batman probably beats them up a little
bit smacks them around and then hands
them over to the cops or tells them to
change their ways or something like that
then there's matches malone and that's
an identity that most of you guys who
have never read batman have probably
never heard of matches malone is the
street level identity of bruce wayne if
he wants to like infiltrate a criminal
underground network or something like
that he'll appear as matches malone and
then get the information he needs and
then suddenly batman will show up and
like just start beating the crap out of
everybody you know just different things
like that with mark spector it's almost
the exact same way steve grant is the
billionaire persona of mark specter and
a lot of that's just the result of money
he's saved up over the years and he's
made as a mercenary things like that
that he's invested and just made himself
super rich but the steve grant persona
allows him to basically know what's
going on in the white collar world when
it comes to crime and also allows him
access to resources and things like that
that he wouldn't normally be able to get
then you have jake lockley jake lockley
is the the cab driver persona right that
he's basically the identity that mark
specter uses to know what's going on on
the ground level and then you have mark
spector the mercenary that's who moon
knight was before he became moon knight
right just a guy with a history of
military training and so on who
basically turned his skills into
becoming a soldier of fortune right that
sort of thing and so once he was injured
and left for dead by raul bushman and
taken before the statue of konchu then
kanchu in turn said become my avatar on
earth and i will basically resurrect you
and mark spectre said okay and then mark
spectre developed the moonlight persona
for himself and then after developing
the moon knight persona developed the
identities of steve grant and and jake
lockley right so uh that's kind of how
his personalities work in unison but
there is a moment in the trailer when of
course the moonlight persona basically
stares back at uh at mark spector or
steve grant or whatever personality we
want to go with right so him just kind
of seeing that out there konshu does
appear in the hallway and of course
again we'll kind of circle back to all
these points here a little bit in terms
of what they mean and then near the end
of the trailer moon night's beating up
what looks like werewolf by night i
don't know if you guys noticed that it's
obviously way too big to be a person
right i mean if that's a person that
person is like seven feet tall right so
maybe moon knight's just beating up a
basketball player who knows but it looks
like it looks like werewolf by night
to be honest with you guys now that also
makes sense because for the most part
when it comes to things like werewolves
vampires stuff like that those are the
natural enemies of conscience so for
those of you guys who don't know how
this works konchu is the god of the moon
right he's a moon god he's one of many
gods that exist out there but the enemy
of khanshu is anybody who would hunt
down and attack people in the night
right werewolf by night vampires things
like that they are the mortal enemies of
kanchu and as an extension of konchu
being his avatar on earth they are the
mortal enemies of moon knight now a lot
of that change in terms of the the
affiliation of like the midnight suns
basically moon knight working alongside
what were in effect his mortal enemies
in order to achieve a greater goal
different things along those lines is
very very fast and loose in terms of who
moon knight considers to be an enemy and
who he considers to be a good guy that
it's not really as heavy-handed as how
konchu puts it that anybody who's a
werewolf is a bad guy anybody who's a
vampire is a bad guy instead moon knight
bases that largely on
how he interacts with them right like
are they vampires that try to kill
people then they're bad guys are they
vampires that try to do good things
they're not bad guys i.e that's why he's
friends with blake i guess maybe friends
is a very very strong term the important
thing is that looking over the entirety
of this trailer you know what this show
reminds me of it reminds me of legion
right those guys should never watch
legion on fx that show the first season
anyway it really begged the question is
what's happening real is any of it real
or is it really just legion dealing with
a combination of having well i guess
this disassociative identity disorder
people were getting all bit out of shape
because i called it multiple personality
disorder
in any event uh it is really a result of
legion having multiple personalities
combined with schizophrenia the
inability to distinguish reality from
fantasy or is it actually happening what
this trailer looks like as far as the
show goes is it looks like we're just
jumping straight into it right like
we're not really getting your standard
fare of the marvel cinematic universe
stuff right whereas once upon a time
there was a guy named mark spector who
was in the military and then once he got
out he started becoming a soldier of
fortune and then was basically ambushed
and left for dead by what he thought was
his business partner and then he was
taken before the statue of the moon god
konchu who promised to bring him back to
life if he would operate as conscious
avatar on earth and now we are here
at the continuation of the story but
it's not following that kind of linear
path which is very much refreshing what
it looks like is it looks like we just
pick up with one of the personas as it's
sort of navigating the life of what is
an effect mark specter and we are
learning about the other personalities
in the mind of mark spector as mark
spector's learning about them as well
right so literally we're figuring it out
as he's figuring it out so that's why
you see things where like he basically
ends up grabbing that phone that was
essentially hidden away and he didn't
know what was there it says unknown
number he doesn't understand why that
person calls him mark when as far as
he's concerned his name is steve grant
because one of the things to understand
is that more often than not at least the
way that marvel depicts the alternate
personalities of of of moon knight that
the other personalities are not really
aware of any of the other personalities
they can be to a degree but by the time
this whole thing of having multiple
personalities took over that like jake
lockley didn't really know about steve
grant and steve grant didn't really know
about jake lockley and mark spector
seemingly didn't know about either or at
least if he did he would simply just
kind of black out for a while and then
come back that sort of thing all that
came to a head in jeff lemire's run when
basically mark spector ended up bringing
all those personalities together and
forcing them to confront each other
essentially retaking control of his mind
it was a really really really cool story
but that looks like is you know what's
going on here that we're basically just
kind of being thrown into this tv show
in the midst of just the middle of
everything right like mark spector
figuring out that he's basically got
multiple personalities each one of these
personalities has an identity of its own
that basically seems to operate absent
of any of the other personalities they
don't know who they are he just kind of
blocks out for a period of time like
when it looks like he's driving the
vehicle and suddenly just comes to and
he's got a gun in his hand he's like
what the hell is going on right like
that kind of a thing so again it's it's
really really curious now in terms of
arthur harrow right in terms of ethan
hawk i mean it's weird that they pick
arthur harrow right this guy appeared in
uh in was it moon knight vol 2. so
technically it was moon knight the fist
of kanchu storyline um and it was it's
it was really like a six issue mini
series so i don't know if i'd really
call it like a full volume but arthur
harrell appeared in that right he was in
like issue number two and he was there
for just a single story right like that
was it but he was there for like a
single story and there wasn't really
anything going on besides that and so
it's a little strange to see them go in
that direction i mean it does allow them
to kind of take the character in any
direction they want to as you guys know
from the marvel cinematic universe one
of the things they love to do is take
ridiculously obscure characters that
nobody really knows anything about and
that nobody really cares anything about
and then just rework that character into
their own vision which is a lot easier
to do with somebody who appeared in one
comic versus someone like captain
america right i mean if the marvel
cinematic universe had launched and like
steve rogers was actually a kid who was
bitten by a radioactive spider and then
lost his uncle ben and then lost his
girlfriend all that kind of stuff it'd
be kind of like okay this is a little
weird right but if you take somebody
like arthur harrow that very very very
few people have ever heard of and you
rework them nobody's gonna care right
it's not really gonna matter to anybody
but ethan hawkes said that the role of
arthur harrow was largely based on david
koresh now here's the reason why this
guy appears is always a kind of cult
leader right because david koresh was so
a little bit of history here uh in 1992
there was a guy by the name of larry
gilbert who was a ups driver and he was
dropping a package off to a compound in
waco texas and the package fell and
broke open and he realized inside this
package were basically automatic assault
rifles which had been banned the year
before in the assault rifles weapons ban
and so the results of this is he had for
the local police who informed the bureau
of alcohol tobacco and firearms in turn
the atf launched his own investigation
and came to the realization that inside
this compound is basically a religious
sect called the branch davidians which
are led by a guy named david koresh and
they were essentially stockpiling arms
and armament to prepare for the end
times not only that david koresh and
other male members of the branch
civilians were engaging in inappropriate
actions with minors and so ultimately
the atf received a warrant to search the
premises they tried to execute the
warrant when they were fired on by the
branch davidians this led to the fbi
intervening and what's come to be known
as the siege of waco now at the end of
the siege of waco which i believe was
like a 52-day standoff the fbi raided
the compound fire was set in three
different locations and when the smoke
cleared and the shooting stopped 76
branch davidian men women and children
had died now in response to the actions
of the federal government at waco texas
and their actions in ruby ridge a year
before a former member of the us
military named timothy mcveigh
basically came to the conclusion that
the federal government was becoming
tyrannical and intended to stop this by
using the federal government's own
foreign policy against itself so he
filled a moving truck full of explosives
drove it to the federal building in
oklahoma city and blew it in half so
that's the whole thing when it comes to
waco texas and all that kind of stuff
right that very much ethan hawk's
character is based on this kind of cult
leader and really the most popular cult
leader really kind of comes in twos that
it's either jim jones or it is uh david
koresh and it'd be kind of weird if at
the end of the show ethan hawk feeds all
of his followers kool-aid and they all
just kill over and die and so it makes
more sense he'd be more akin to a david
koresh type character and so the thing
about this is we don't really know
exactly what's going on in this show but
it does look cool right the show itself
does look amazing i mean regardless i'm
excited for it man like i'm excited for
the kind of adventure because it has so
much mystery and intrigue right i mean
one of the things that was done in the
early days of the moon night comics is
that mark spector was depicted as having
multiple personalities but marvel
labeled that incorrectly as
schizophrenia but marvel also dove into
the idea that maybe everything mark
specter is experiencing is not actually
happening that maybe he's a person that
really does have schizophrenia and
that's kind of what it looks like here
right it looks like marvel's going with
a combination of mark spector having
different personalities inside his own
head with little touches of
schizophrenia here and there for example
seeing this god consciou in the hallway
as he's like in an elevator right i mean
is that actually happening or is he
imagining it right like is he unable to
differentiate between reality and
fantasy so let me know what you guys
think down in the in the comments right
let me know how you guys feel about this
trailer again it was a pretty basic
trailer not a lot of stuff to go on here
but it looks great so we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching i will catch
you all later
peace